oh not this please no no no know what it
is yeah I know what it is nobody nobody
missed this one this week I don't care
how much [__] Starfield we were
playing nobody missed this one so the
daily hold on everyone calm
down so you know how the Rachel zler is
like one of the worst people in the
world and that Snow White's going to
fail and all that stuff
well don't worry much like candy bars
daily wire has swooped
in and
decided they're going to make have you
seen this
Virgie I I've seen a little tiny piece
of it and I knew it was on the show do
you know do you know do you know who's
you know who's playing Snow
White yeah Benjo
x23
enjoy Once Upon a Time
time in time a
[Music]
prince even their apples look like [__]
I'm [__] cring but now that time is
[Music]
gone
[Laughter]
this never gets old I laugh at this like
five times this weekend why is Snow
White Jewish very Jewish so we're okay
with zler not being snow okay I get it
it's [__] it's Ben Shapiro's x23 and
I have to say look I have seen like you
know her on her show and I've seen her
at times where you go man she's kind of
cute she's kind of [__] able this ain't
the right look for you this highlights
all the wrong features see if they can
film the whole the whole movie on a
Logitech webcam listen Jewish Ladi
Jewish women listen listen listen to
shaboy
umy shoy uh you guys can be very pretty
with a with a certain Stu it's like
black women or blonde women or certain
looks certain things highlight certain
there's a way to look nice right you
know hair down over the ear
uh maybe a little hide the profile a
little bit but like my
God so the
movie is going snow not white SN not
have you seen some of the
comments perfect casting Still Still
Melanie Mack perfect casting still why
is it perfect casting what other work
has this woman been on as a good actress
because that's the problem with all you
[__] nerds all you little conser a
nerds they not nerd she's a clout Goblin
is there anything worse than [__]
Melanie Mack on the internet right now J
picket internet specific oh internet
sphere like just when you see them on
your timeline have you ever went oh yeah
right
on or just every time I see her on my
timeline I
go I don't even a follower bro it's
other people going what's a base take
Melanie oh I like your butter videos
Michaela Peterson Michaela Peterson so
cool you all make me sick you [__]
saying things like great casting how do
you know it's perfect casting what if
she's and probably is but what if she's
a [__] actress what if she's I get the
impression she will be this isn't
something oh this is the [__] we were
saying every time we talk about these
[__] people just because it's on your
side doesn't mean it's [__] good the
same thing with isome the same thing
with all you [__] idiots just because
the person the person is politically
agrees with you all of the sudden their
[__] is good no it's [__] not all
right Bill O'Reilly writes romance
novels and [__] and and [__]
historical Thrillers they all
suck yeah I I you know I just this will
be no but this is historic this will be
the first um this will be the first time
Snow White uh had her last name
shortened oh yeah yeah
yeahuh Snow Snow White you know and
there was some other letters in there
back in the day and the story of her
early life turns out the wicked witch
was anti-Semitism all along yes Thomas
Jane is Prince
Charming we always talk about the seven
dwarves in the evil witch story why
don't we like I don't do a prequel we
can call it Snow White's early life
Jesus
Christ oh my God BR and it's it's going
to you know what's going to be and I'll
give Royce credit cuz he said this on
Twitter this is going to be just as bad
as their snow wiper for opposite reasons
for completely different reasons this is
going to be bad because it's going to be
pandering the other way and the
production values are not going to be
there look we've seen daily wire movies
and some of our Rifts the production
value is not great this but just just go
back like two set just to where the
graphic pops up on screen and tell me it
doesn't feel like a TV
movie Hallmark
that's what I mean it's a TV movie Evil
Queen does that the great dude there are
look Hollywood I get it all right it's
all run by Nephilim [__] evil
pedophile weirdos I get it they all
worship baffet I get it but they're on
the money when they make some of these
movies right like with the way it looks
and sounds production quality yeah
that's when they no I mean nowadays all
the [__] everything CGI now but yeah but
I mean like back in the day like you'd
look at something and go whoa that
trailer made me want to go [__] see
that dude and that doesn't even that
wouldn't even look good for a video game
start screen we've come a long way since
Blade Runner my friend here's where we
are
now oh we will rip this when it comes
out oh yeah somebody said next movie RI
we can't do it the next one but it's not
even out it's not it's not even filmed
yet this is a teaser it's not even
filmed yet but yes this will be this
will be riffed the moment this is
released it's getting ried we are going
to be riffing it on our locals 100% 100%
um and what bothers me like is is all
the people like it's so good oh my god
oh look this gives me Star Wars girl
this gives me Twilight
Vibes dude shut up cons conservatives
will literally eat a pile of [__] if you
rap it an American flag honestly like
stop being so gullible with these people
stop by $26 chocolate bars Tom McDonald
Eric July it's just it how many times do
you watch the same story over and over
again and it's always the same clout
Goblin [__] [__] in the replies
yeah MCH but did you know that if you go
to daily wire plus you get a you get a
whole thing of Children's shows here's
another
one no hi you made it oh hello want to
play I've seen enough these two are
ready or not they just like ripped off
Bluey and [__] Peppa Pig and [__]
mhm yeah and they have paw police
they're also they're also ripping off
every streaming platform commercial yeah
from the song to the [__] format to
everything it's just bad photo copy of
what they do Ben Shapiro has always
wanted to be in Hollywood his mother was
in Hollywood that's what he wants he'll
I'm telling you that's what he wants to
be he wants to be involved in film
making and now he can be and he's going
to make shitty right-wing Kirk Cameron
level quality [__] movies just
because you agree with them doesn't mean
you give the money to them you're going
to give money to the [__] for the
company that's run by the [__] dude
that wants to go to war with
Iran I gotta say though do you think
that
Crowder right now regrets not taking the
daily wire deal because he loves playing
dress up and being a [__] fairy and
he probably would have gotten paid
outside of his daily wire contract to be
in all this all these [__] movies
Crowder this is right up Crowder's alley
you would have Lov this production
[__] you know a budget and like a
snow white thing where he gets to dress
like a half a f but you're not telling
me the Crowder is not thinking right now
like I really [__] myself I sold
myself short cuz now I could have been
in these you don't think Crowder
wouldn't have pitched to Ben Shapiro
what if the evil queen is trans or a
dragon and I get to play it and then we
can tell me he wouldn't pitch that yeah
he probably it's another excuse for him
to wear a dress and get another paycheck
yeah kit wacky at Crowder's
Playhouse I would rather hang out in the
firef flin house yeah legs inside the
cck I would rather hang out in Bray W
it's
coffin Bye Bill see you later
bill hurry up the party is starting
this is wow you're right though that
just this is just garbage Peppa Pig
ripoffs where is he going we're going on
a treasure hunt we're exploring the wild
blue yonder it's Chilla
time I would I want to I want to know I
want to I want somebody to look up all
of the shows I want to see some of these
shows and forget about the shows I want
everyone to look up all these shows and
I want you to go read the credits for
them and I want you to tell me where all
of the animators names are I wantan I
want to know what the animator's names
sound like ethnically because there's
gonna be a lot of Vietnamese a lot of
[__] watch a lot of Vietnamese a lot
of Malaysians Singapore
watch
uh pretty incredible it's unbelievable
you guys whether big or little little or
big we all have fabulous adventures
together I'm just saying it Ben Shapiro
Mr America you know America at least
close second to Israel uh is is hiring
all of his uh if all of his [__]
animators and [__] are all these [__]
little shady [__] firms yeah Mr
America first I had one of their shows
created like a children's television
show Bill chasing and hanging out huh
huh huh what do you think fish remember
that remember fish
yo what the [__] I was looking for an
actual clip of fiveish but instead I got
like [__] somebody talking about it
here it is toown yeah here it is here it
is here it is here it is remember
[Music]
this who thought this was a good idea a
Jewish guy the cars for kids
guy that was a cars for kids I know
that's just insane to me yeah so you
ready for these kids shows virgy are
your kids going to be daily wire plus
kids it's time to head off for adventure
look around I would rather drown them in
the bathtub like Chris Watts than ever
subject them to this garbage a drum
solo imagine this hey parents download
the Ben key app new so Ben key is like
the name of it mhm yeah I'm looking up
some of the shows now and look at the
comment explain name beny it's a really
weird without context if there is any so
even his own fans are like that's a
weird name is there any satanic
undertones to it Rob Schneider is on the
uh the the chip Chilla at the [__]
show so his career is done
yeah Ben key is the name of the whole is
the name of the daily wires holding
company oh that doesn't explain the name
though yeah that doesn't explain the
name I mean I mean okay cool I guess but
like that isn't really why but why is it
called
that